okay so xbox one game of the year just
like PlayStation 4 we had some overlap
Dragon Age middle-earth far cry 4
everyone had a lot of love for um pushed
him around tight folder yeah which was
an excellent game and also we had a lot
of love for ground zeroes but like
PlayStation 4 we went with shadow of
mordor again and something else that
really captivated us was the combat
system is the right to control by not
it's easy to look at shadow of Mordor
and say okay well this is what
Assassin's Creed should be and you know
here's a little bit of Assassin's Creed
here's a little bit of Arkham will throw
it in the middle earth and call it a
game right it's really easy to like look
at it from that sort of shallow
superficial kind of hot level
perspective but I think what's
interesting is they've shown how you can
take you know you can stand on the
shoulders of giants and you can take
something that we're already familiar
with tweak it in really interesting
vital ways and suddenly make it fresh
and new and exciting again I look at
things like okay so you have you know
like Assassin's Creed for example you
know you can do things that are stealthy
but there's no reason to do any of that
didn't always use the right it didn't
always used to be that way but at this
point it's like you know path of least
resistance is almost always combat in an
assassin creed is so different in shadow
of mordor those firefights are like if
you get in there and there's like 10 of
them it's like you can get in real
trouble yeah I mean it the first time I
was really flabbergasted actually the
first time I thought oh
be able to rhythmically push my buttons
until i win and no there are three well
seems like 300 Eric I just to sending on
me and your choice is to just get the
flock out of there or or try and and
fail some of the time and that's not
something that I'm used to in a third
person action game how amazing then that
one little tweak alone just the tweet of
challenge can change so much suddenly
you have systems that are not just there
to round out the game it's like oh you
can do it this way you can do it this
way now they're meaningful you know now
you can do it this way and you might
actually have to think about doing it
that way yoooo mortar did which hasn't
happened in an assassin's creed game in
forever and maybe this is why go down
the entire list of our nominees there's
not assassins creed mentioned once right
is that I fled a battle I got out of
there I was notified able to kill these
people I need to get the hell out and
that hasn't happened since I'm a BAC one
or possibly two I can't just button mash
my way out of this situation I know if
you get to a certain level in Mordor you
can sort of try and end up doing that
but like you're actually asked to think
about combat and that's something that
doesn't happen that often anymore in
third person action game and the best
thing about that is when you run away
from battles they should talk you you
didn't go on them oh I was fighting him
in and he ran away from me and like if
you kill their buddy you can sneak up on
works in a camp and they'll be talking
about you I boys lost when I told them
about your grant the world is there
where that you are there and that's
awesome i love having my enemies talk
[ __ ] about my rate is then you get the
stuff nap let me come back with iron
plates and then they go yeah then you
get to stop them in the neck
you